[Music]
[Music]
hey hey hey
[Applause]
the way yell because it makes the
spirits hear us that we're here in the
canyon the spirits in the ruins should
know people are going into the canyon
we want them to know we are there
because they protect us some of my
grandma's died in there my dad wants
them to hear his kids that were born
that's how they get to know us that's
how it feels in the canyon when they go
in there
parametric leonitia say it's a mr. P
indicia while we're in the canyon we
start getting excited and we get to
explore things that we haven't seen
before I start talking to each other for
a long time about all these stories in
the Kenya there's some stories on the
walls from a long time ago
it's about clans from what you're
related to talk behind the smile she
helped us achieve how did you need SJ
Hana and that's another
[Music]
and Navajo culture when it comes to a
person that doesn't know their clans
they call him or her and abandon Indian
and abandon Indian usually meant that
their parents don't teach them about
their culture what they have to care
about and what their clans are my name
is Daniel Draper I live and Canyon de
Chelly that first I was really negative
about Navajo tradition because I grew up
in the church my paternal grandfather
was a preacher but my maternal
grandfather said to me US natives after
DNA of a tree and I started learning
myself how we do have a Navajo tradition
and that's why I try to teach my kids
from the Anasazi time corn was planted
and the way that what people used to
give lands to each other a long time ago
was generation the generation to the
oldest daughter and I want them to keep
the tradition going
I love that my dad is teaching me these
things because I get to learn more about
my Navajo tradition my Navajo culture in
my Navajo language
I slept in another cave and I was
growing up most peaceful place in the
world at night they sleep here at night
you can do people talk different ideas
you can talk to them but you can hear
them talk to each other you know what
they say hey we have a visitor
[Music]
our family chipped back from that log
wall to candy shell and we should live
down there when we were down there you
know you should use wagons and horses
and we're herding sheep taking care of
the cows they supplied by the stuff
cantaloupe beasts carrots it was fun and
I missed it
when we were growing up at the boarding
school we were not supposed to talk now
our own language when we speak them over
to each other we should get our mouth
wash with soap and we supposed to just
wait my people just and we're not
supposed to have long hair we went to
church too we live in two different
cultures but we're trying to survive
[Music]
talisha
is my second granddaughter she would
have my name Dave people call her a
dolla because just doing what I'm doing
and how I'm hacking
[Music]
how the scene and how to dress up and
how to introduce herself in Navajo and
what her tan is and all that stuff she
learned it from me I am 2014-2015 my
central nap opt to be in the project my
grandmother taught me the Navajo
language and she's the person who taught
me all the songs I know
[Music]
I'd like to keep going through all these
pageants and be Miss Venetian these
young ladies they're really unique
you guys all look beautiful to be in
that project you have to put your sheet
and name all the parts in Navajo and you
have to make tortillas and fry bread for
the judges and before the contestant I
would like to say good luck to you all
and if you lose you're still a winner
inside I feel kind of happy and sad at
the same time the happy part is about
the things I did in my community
the sad part is I gave up my crown to a
young little girl and I hope she would
do the same as I did
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've seen a lot of different natives
that are not keeping their tradition
alive they're losing their heritage and
their language I wasn't really here for
my kids when I was a young guy I didn't
really teach them anything because I was
working on the road most of the time as
a nutrition and last year my wife trying
to tell me to go back on the road but
could I do that I wanted to stay around
my kids and teach them more and more of
the Navajo tradition that's what for me
and cherish the most
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I had to do some kind of prayer before
we beat the corn see if it's good or not
I hope and a hundred years after my
grandkids will learn from their dads
about all these stories in the canyon my
dad told me when we're using the Jinyu
we usually get leaves off the trees and
we just say goodbye and please drop the
leaves into the water
it's our special way to say goodbye to
all the fun we've been having them when
we leave all those feelings stay in the
canyon
[Music]
I read just that is last night you
posted that someone else was holding
your time you shut up for all our
friends to see I don't wanna go do this
Facebook drama so I press the Li way hey
wayya hey uh hi oh well hey y'all hey
y'all hey wayya way hey oh hey hey oh
hey oh hi oh hey hey oh hey oh hey oh
[Music]